[Musique]
voici claudia cardinale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir claudia cardinale et toujours
somptueuse
vous avez déclaré vieillir ne me dérange
pas il n'y a rien de plus triste que les
femmes qui multiplie les liftings penser
que les hommes le voit que la hoya tu
parles
alors ils sont jeunes mais au moins je
vois de très loin ouais on voit que vous
n'avez pas fait en tous les cas merci
faire réduire ça veut dire que vous
n'avez pas fait d'ici et que ça se voit
bien sur wii
alors vous êtes une star énorme fêtée
partout vous dites c'est le temps des
récompenses et c'est vrai que tous les
festivals vous rendent hommage cannes
hollywood venise tout le monde salue vos
cinquante ans de carrière
mais vous dites je parle encore 50 à 49
ennemis 45 première gaffe
ouais y en aura d'autres tirées alors
vous dites je ne veux pas entrer au
musée c'est vrai que vous n'entrez pas
aux musées au contraire vous monter sur
les planches puisque vous vous revenez
au théâtre à partir du 8 février sur la
scène du théâtre de la madeleine dans
une pièce de tennessee williams qui
s'appelle 12 l'oiseau de jeunesse mise
en scène de philippe adrien avec vous
christophe raymond bernard verley alors
c'est l'histoire d'une star
vieillissante qui s'appelle princesse
qui est riche et qui partage sa vie avec
un jeune acteur raté bon jeu crête de
peur je suis déjà morte je suis momifié
il dit que dans deux semaines je vais
être là bas quoi moi j'ai toujours la
trouille j'ai toujours très peur ouais
ça commence et les cauchemars et les
cauchemars c'est à dire les autres non
mais moi ça c'est même au cinéma
j'arrive trois heures avant les
techniciens oui c'est ignoble étiez là
aujourd'hui vous étiez là cet après midi
vers
génial non mais c'est quoi l'histoire de
cette pièce c'est quand même intéressant
on n'avait pas été très intéressant ce
qui m'a fasciné c'est justement c'est
l'histoire d'une d'une star qui pensent
naturellement que son succès dépend de
la jeunesse dont elle commence à se
droguer à boire et complètement mais
alors folle rencontre le jeune homme et
elle utilise un peu parce que ce qu'elle
aime c'est aussi faire l'amour
bon moi c'est pas du tout c'est à dire
moi je suis pas du tout comme ça ah bon
non on annule celle où ça perd beaucoup
de son intérêt dans ce sens que je suis
pas du tout une star adacore 6 et ce
alors dire ça donc j'ai découvert le
théâtre à 60 ans avec une pièce qui
s'appelle la vénitienne vous devez
guerre toujours l'âge ah ouais d'accord
je dis pas vous avez découvert le
théâtre la soixantaine il ya quelques
sait pas exactement quand on mai 2000 on
peut dire en mai 2000 claudio voilà dans
une pièce s'appelle la vénitienne au
théâtre du rond point
alors il y avait catherine allégret dans
cette pièce qui a quel âge mais pourquoi
vous dites toujours l'âge des femmes et
pas des hommes ben c'est un truc qui
nous a pris ce soir comme d'habitude on
fait pas ça vous avez lu le livre de
catherine allégret oui vous en avez
pensé quoi écouter catherine c'est
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup
non mais dis simplement sur l'a3 je suis
scandalisée je revienne
moi je crois que les gens sont libres de
dire ce qu'il pense ouais alors la vie
la vénitienne s'était déjà l'histoire
d'une femme d'un certain âge disons
qu'ils s'amouracher d'un certain seuil
certains diront nous la soixantaine
quand même oui il ya aussi un petit
jeune
ouais ouais les petits jeunes voient ses
fans mais claire était là oui
non moi je suis pas toujours les petits
jeunes non non dans sa gueule bien des
bien des années plus tôt visconti vous
avez proposé de faire du théâtre
l'époque vous pensiez vous n'étiez pas
prêtre pourquoi bas d'abord avec mal n'a
voilà louis armstrong
je pensais que personne n'entendrait et
puis moi j'ai toujours très peur j'ai
fait plus de 150 films et vous voici
toujours le premier ouais
personnellement vous avez peur j'ai
toujours terre et au théâtre
finalement c'est quoi qui vous a décidé
finalement à vous lancer parce que ben
parce que la caméra est quelque chose de
rigide et de froid tandis que quand tu
trouves de sur la scène tu sens la
respiration des gens parfois la laine si
au premier rang ça arrive
si j'étais lui deux buts il ya des gens
qui pue de la gueule qui vont au théâtre
que lunel
mais c'est pas ça que je voulais bien
alors vous racontez vous raconter ça
comment vous avez refusé de de faire du
théâtre à visconti ce que quand même
énorme frais l'air est hideuse et voilà
j'ai même refusé de faire une comédie
musicale à broadway
ouais j'ai toujours refusé vous raconter
tout ça dans un livre qui sort chez
michel lafon qui s'appelle les étoiles
et qui parle de ceux qui ont compté pour
vous c'est ça vaut étoiles c'est ce
qu'ils ont contre toutes les étoiles que
j'ai rencontré les gens de ma carrière
alors visconti fellini sergio leone
mastroianni bertrand questeur john wayne
brondeau enfin voilà lyonnais y en a
encore plein de latrines d'un grand dieu
alors j'ai lu votre bouquin claudia j'ai
trouvé ça très intéressant comme
histoire vraiment vraiment très
intéressant je vais essayer de faire
partager à miami téléspectateurs là
l'intérêt que j'ai eue pour ce livre
absolument et c'est très intéressant
quand ça commence à tunis un la
naissance la naissance à tunis puisque k
o dia est né en afrique comme tout le
monde le sait dans quelle année il n'y a
pas d' année il n'y avait pas l'année
sur la fiche alors dites moi votre année
de naissance à 58 58
ouais machine un petit peu à 20,56 vos
parents sont nés en tunisie mais vos
grands parents étaient de purs sicilien
oui trois générations voilà on est
arrivés avant les français oui alors à
l'époque la tunisie était française est
pour beaucoup de français
l'italie reste et dites-vous un pays
fasciste alors il fallait faire profil
bas quand on était l'italien en tunisie
à l'époque de votre naissance dire que
d'abord à l'école on nous appelait pas
cardinal et les cardinals épi plaque
claudio mais claude alors la tunisie à
l'époque était un protectorat français
mais il y avait l'indépendance qui ce
qui se profilait à l'horizon est un
garçon débarque là bas rené vautier 26
ans qui militait caméra au poing et ils
voulaient raconter la vie des marins
tunisiens ils n'arrivaient pas à voir
des femmes tunisiennes dans son film et
vous a choisi voix oui j'étais une femme
voilée
et puis
le dernier plan de ce documentaire c'est
un coup de vent et là ça finit avec le
gros plan le film a eu un très gros
succès au festival de berlin il a gagné
tout ça voilà
april a été diffusée dans tous les
cinémas de tunis et vous êtes devenu une
célébrité locale
voilà juste à cause de ceux de ce voile
qui se soulève comme ça là à la fin du
film j'avais 15 ans est encore au lycée
ok là naissent un ça suffit c'est le
destin
franchement non oui non mektoub mektoub
là franchement
ensuite jacques baratier vous propose
gohelle simple qu'est le premier film de
marc sharif lui il avait 24 ans u17
comment ils étaient omar sharif quand il
est venu webo était marié à l'époque des
jeunes j'en sais rien moi je parlais pas
j'étais une sauvage un bon c'est pas que
j'allais discuter avec lui pour savoir
si tu es marié ou pas ouais alors la
même année en 56 vous faites un concours
de beauté organisé par une italia qui
vous fait pas en fait tu nous fais toi
le concours de beauté vous avec votre
mère dans la salle du concours de beauté
vous occuper des billets de tombola avec
votre mère et c'est un concours est
organisé par une italia qu'à un peu
comme unifrance film ce qui fait la
promotion du cinéma italien à l'étranger
et à ce moment là quelqu'un me tire la
porte sur scène voilà et j'ai été élue
la plus belle italienne de tunisie on a
offert un voyage pendant le festival de
venise est le premier film que je joue à
venise nuit blanche avec visconti gras
alors finalement vous accepté la
proposition de dunes italia de venir à
rome vous allez à rome vous étudiez le
cinéma dans une dans une école vous vous
ennuyez un peu vous êtes un peu
dépressif qui est froid mais pas que ça
vous avez aussi l'autre histoire c'est à
dire ce type à la à la voiture noire qui
quand même occupé toujours votre votre
esprit non ben il n'occupait pas mon
esprit c'était un peu une angoisse vous
été violée à l'âge de 16 ans par en
français dont vous avez toujours refusé
de de dire le nom il vous continuez à le
voir malgré tout 1
je voulais me tenir c'était pour vous
punir ou alors parce que le fait de
continuer à le voir finalement c'était
plus un violent puisque vous continuez à
le voir c'était pour vous punir alors là
quand vous êtes assez dépressive vous
pensé au suicide à cette époque un voilà
et puis donc en 1958 vous découvrez que
vous êtes enceinte de ce type vous
refusé d'avorter vous repartez à rome où
vous signez un contrat avec franco
cristal dick est un producteur important
à l'époque en italie et là vous tournez
le pigeon de monicelli qu'un film
magnifique qui a eu un succès colossal
film avec mastroianni gassmann totaux
ouais et plus grandes stars de l'époque
quoi et là vous devenez en quelques mois
la petite fiancée du talent vie quoi oui
en plus je parlais pas un mot d'italien
donc je comprenais rien j'avais
l'impression d'être sur mars sur la lune
et donc je parlais français ont fait
trois films là jusqu'au septième mois de
votre grossesse et à ce moment là
effectivement on pouvais plus tourner
parce que ça ça se voit terriblement et
la crystal difranco cristaldi vous
organise finalement un voyage à londres
en disant qu'à un projet ultra secret
dont on peut pas parler et vous aller
accoucher à londres et il vous ordonne
de dire que cet enfant n'est pas votre
fils mais votre frère et pendant des
années vous vous raconterez ça vous
aussi parce que moi je ne savais pas
quand on signe un contrat on était
prisonnière
j'étais très jeune ce qui est tout à
fait notable dans votre histoire cloud
ya c'est que vous êtes soumises dans un
premier temps aux tipa la voiture noire
pour vous en échappée vous allez à rome
vous gardez votre enfance qui vous
honorent évidemment mais ensuite vous
devenez aussi très très soumise à franco
cristal dire que vous quittez une
soumission pour une autre mais le
problème c'est que moi j'ai accepté de
faire du cinéma justement pour affronter
le problème ou un mms que j'en avais
parlé à personne
donc pour moi je vais à rome je fais un
contrat voilà je pars
vous avez du mal quand même avec lui et
que ce franco christelle dit là parce
que vous n'avez même pas à vous dites
pour raconter ça vous arrivez pas
l'appeler franco vous l'appelez cristal
dire que vous vous l'admiré mais vous
l'aimez pas on voit bien c'était c'était
un homme très cultivé très intelligent
c'était le 20 des producteurs le plus
important d'europe 1
oui mais il était très obsédé par son
travail aussi un oui j'ai dit que la
seule chose qui l'intéressait c'était
son immeuble avec ses bureaux alors un
jour vous décidé de dire la vérité à
votre fils qui prend le nom de crystal
dit puisque vous aviez épousé
entre-temps franco cristaldi atlanta que
c'est pas que je l' ai épousé c'est à
dire que c'était un piège
il avait tout organisé moi j'étais pas
au courant mais un jour il arrive ça
attendra à jouer la révision se marie
ouais voilà je devais rien pu faire mais
c'était déjà tout organiser mais le
mariage n'a jamais été déclarée autre
part donc je me suis jamais mariés ouais
vous a été piégé un petit peu
affectivement et financièrement parce
dans ce cristal d'une famille pas ce que
je fais et quatre films par an je gagne
des sommes folles et moi on me paye et
comme petit employé voilà et ça je les
fais pas lent 17 ans alors je les faire
des tas de films entre 1958 et 1973 les
faire 50 films dont le guépard huit et
demi la viaccia la panthère rose alors
vous faites aussi le plus grand cirque
du monde avec rita hayworth
et il ya cette phrase terrible c'est à
dire qu'un jour vous la voyez arriver
sur le plateau était déjà assez âgées
elle picoler pas mal elle avait des
bleus sur la gueule et elle vous dit moi
aussi j'ai été belle ça a été terrible
terrible ça m'a fait pleurer mais c'est
ce métier si tu est fragile il vaut
mieux ne pas le faire ouais vous faites
aussi les professionnels cartouches les
pétroleuses et brigitte bardot oui enfin
c'est très marrant ce que vous racontez
sur brigitte bardot parce que en fait
vous devez vous battre contre elle et
vous vous retrouvez en train de vous
battre contre un figurant espagnol en
fait un homme parce que parce que moi
j'ai toujours fait dans tous les films
tous les effets spéciaux même trapet
cheval tout parce que je suis une grande
sportive j'adore le sport reste un peu
garçon manqué quand je suis un gars au
cdh en savoir encore plus excitant
milieu là d'un coup parce que j'ai
toujours vous nous trouvez que c'est pas
vrai que les femmes sont faibles voilà
tu pour ça que je ne comportait comme ça
et donc vous battez avec ceux figurant
et puis au bout d'un moment on vous dit
c'est pas possible tu dois me battre
contre un mais qu'il avait des poils sur
la poitrine tout ça et vous avez voir
bardot et vous arrivez à la convaincre
génial de vraiment se battre contre vous
avez peur oui parce que parce que tout
le monde dit que j'étais un mec moi je
m'entraîne et je faisais de la boxe
ouais ouais oui j'ai touché athlétisme
basket volley tout mais là on s'est bien
amusé et alors vous l'avez fait mal non
pas du tout non après mais non parce que
on s'était entraîné c'est à dire quand
il donne un coup de poing il faut que tu
bouges ton visage au même moment vincent
que tu le touches quoi alors c'est fou
c'est quand je lis votre bouquin le
nombre de mecs auquel vous avez résisté
ce extraordinaire marcello mastroianni
vraiment quand même le mec le plus
séduisant du monde quoi et il a
d'ailleurs dit avant sa mort j'ai
toujours été amoureux d'elle mais elle
ne m'a jamais crue cirque en fait il a
passé sa vie à vous déclarer son amour
quoi
j'y croyais toujours pas là oui oui il a
toujours dit ya toujours 10 mai
moi je suis pas du tout une femme facile
bah oui pas dans les pièges
ouais pourquoi vous pensez toujours
c'est un piège il peut être sincère le
mec
oui mais moi je suis pas affolé pour les
flirts et les avants timmins est
d'accord moi je donne de l'importance à
un rapport très puissant très fort
passion de coeur c'est pas la femme d'un
soir voilà non mais c'est pas grave il
ya d'autres invités à ce que luc ferry
alors vous avez résisté à marcello
mastroianni à brando comme
extraordinaire quand même la scène avec
brando et terry dans votre bouquin quand
vous marchez vers lui vous regarde il
est comme ça il a eu tout bon dos il a
eu marre et une bonne ronde james dean
et ils vous voient arriver et vous vous
juger comme ça en plus c'était dans ma
suite au ballet will charlotte quand je
tournais là bas donc il est monté il a
fait tout son humeur axor soudure et il
savait très bien que pour moi lui
c'était un mythe
parce que c'était mon acteur ça toujours
été un acteur préféré mais ça été
amusant parce que on s'est regardé après
qu'il a fait tout son numéro et on s'est
mis à rire il m'a dit voilà j'ai compris
tu es bélier chez bélier j'ai dit non je
tombe pas à toi le 15 avril 18 quelle
année
[Rires]
alors
j'ai 65 ans quand on parle pas obsédé
par l'âge vous avez résisté à marcello
mastroianni à marlon brando et à de niro
vous savez dans la vie on va les cornes
quand y'a un mec qui te court après et
que tu le regardes pas et continue à
courir après si tu dis oui
rochd et est gentil assas élégance est
ce que tu peux jamais sauté tu tu vois
le genre ça c'est les gonzesses du midi
du sud de l'italie à elles sont comme ça
le regard dédaigneux que portent les
filles comme vous sur un mec qui veulent
et ce au tcs voit là badaboum le fait
lorsqu'elle voit guère ça m'énerve
bon alors vous résister à tout le monde
mais quand même elle cède quand même pas
mal elle c'est bart van aelst en 72 vous
cédez à pasquale squitieri squitieri
vous voulez faire le film et c'est lui
qui veut pas il obtint face ne pas il
n'est pas une star voilà dix ans et star
voilà c'est ça ça vous excite et sa non
parce que bon on est d'abord très beau
et donc j'ai décidé c'était lui c'est
tout qu'est ce qu'il avait de plus que
les étés très beau viens de lire encore
mamba marcello mastroianni marlon brando
et robert de niro sont reposés a été mis
à mieux
ouais voilà bien plus il est l ambiance
est un fou déchaîné 1
j'aime les fous ouais c'est un homme
c'est vraiment que ce qu'il avait dit
nous on va faire pareil
eh bien je vais vous le dire a en tous
les cas vous le poursuivait jusqu'à new
york
vous qui avez été tellement fier toute
votre vie avec les mecs d'un seul coup
vous c'est vous qui le harcelaient quoi
oui un que j'avais décidé que c'était
lui art est d'accord donc je vais
arriver avec ma petite valise à new york
1 je sais même pas où il était j'ai
passé un coup de téléphone un copain
alain et il était là alors j'ai dit je
suis à new york il a failli s'évanouir
est ce que tu viens faire juste à temps
via l'aéroport
voila voila et demi
depuis ça dure trente ans et c'est bien
alors il faut c'est qu'à ce moment là
votre producteur la franco cristaldi
vous pensez qu'il était détaché qui
allait se montrer compréhensif pas du
tout il rentre dans une colère noire
il vous flingue dans le métier enfin ils
essayent est-ce que je joue bien sûr
j'annule le contrat jours l'ont trahi
tout ça et je me retrouve avec des
centaines de millions de d'impôt à payer
parce qu'ils n'avaient même pas payer
les impôts alors que moi j'étais payé
trois fois rien voilà alors ce qui est
évident c'est qu'à cette époque là même
10 conti à un moment il va vous prendre
dans l'innocent et il vous prend pas
parce qu'il est pote avec franco
christelle 10 à dire que là d'un seul
coup c'est toujours dans ce cas mais oui
parce que c'était le plus grand
producteur
mais bon avec lou qui nous on a toujours
eu un rapport absolument extraordinaire
c'est à dire ça nous a pas empêchés de
voyager ensemble de et d'être très uni
alors qu'à audiard on l'a vu vous êtes
très très italienne donc on va vous
faire une interview
[ __ ] la audiard est ce que comme une
vraie italienne vous êtes jalouses non
est ce que comme une vraie italienne
vous aimez bien les machos j'aime les
foules et les mecs oui est ce que comme
une vraie italienne nous est possessive
avec votre fils pas du tout ah oui paddy
fait ce qu'il veut
moi mes enfants ils ont vécu tout seul à
14 ans ah oui je leur ai dit toute la
liberté est ce que je suis une femme
libre - c'est pas un peu de temps 80 bas
je pensais que c'était bien
est ce que comme une vraie italienne
vous faites sécher votre linge aux
balkans non puisque comme une vraie
italienne êtes fiers de vos revendeurs
de miranda mais chut aaron est ce qu est
ce que comme une vraie italienne vous
êtes laissé un petit peu aller quand
vous avez été mariée je me suis jamais
marié d'abord elle c'est comme une vague
italienne nous manger des pâtes tous les
jours non je mange très peu je marche
comme un petit oiseau presque comme une
grille de jeu nous est croyante ouicher
cathodique
est-ce que vous finissez toutes vos
phrases par vaffanculo non ça je peux le
dire ce n'est pas habituel quoi c'est
pas elle c'est comme une vraie italienne
où un membre de la famille dans la mafia
non non vous avez un grand frère qui est
un peu trop protecteur non d'accord
donc c'est moi qui les ai je suis comme
une vraie italienne que le stade le
dimanche
j'adore le flou est ce que comme une
brique aliens vous tombez dès qu'on vous
bousculent dans la surface de réparation
non je tombe pas une petite carte à
c'est un nouveau jeu avec des gags
[Musique]
attention 18 ans j'ai un vêtement a pas
mal à j'ai toujours refusé dans les 150
films de me déshabiller mais j'ai fait
faire ce soir
ailleurs un vêtement voilà votre école
voilà
annoncé comme
[Musique]
voilà j'ai bien fait c'est quoi dois
dire vous êtes mal barré je devais
choisir un invité et l'embrassé
[Musique]
c'est quand même et quand même créé
chacun
vous êtes connu dans certains films un
peu plus à l'est en noblesse on
recommence alors toi et moi
[Musique]